luno the fastest easiest way to buy bitcoin
if you're just getting into crypto it's the
perfect place to start hey guys and welcome
back to the lay high or pan show as usual it's
powered by icon plus capital so they're a vc
firm and it is sponsored by block five so with
block five you can get really cool interest
rates um i think it's pretty important given
interest rates are practically zero and if
you're unfortunate enough to live across europe
they're actually negative interest rates so pretty
pretty rubbish so you'll see a link somewhere and
everywhere um if you're interested now joining
me today is a good friend of mine somebody who
i actually interviewed when i first got into
the space so um he is somebody that i that
i've known for a while now and he has a very very
interesting story it is of course my good friend
joel joel how you doing i'm doing fantastic
uh very honored to be on again thanks again
yeah it's really good to chat to you um like i
was saying for those that don't know you're one
of the very first people that i interviewed um
back in was it 2018 when i first started working
professionally in this space yeah i think it
was how are you right i'm doing fantastic i mean
you know the world gets crazier by the minute
but in a lot of good ways as well as bad ways
and i like to focus on those yeah i think we are
very aligned um when it comes to the reason why
we're in crypto what we like about it um in
terms of freedom and everything um but before
we jump into all of that you have a super unique
story it's so interesting um like i said when i
did the show with you i did it because we only
spoke to people who had these really weird and
quirky things going on so for those that
don't know please just tell us your story john
yeah so the bullet point of that is i've
been living unbanked off of crypto for
a little over five years now so that's the
short of it and pretty much the longer of it is
basically i became interested in you know precious
metals and sound money and things with the whole
you know before the ron paul revolution in
american politics but also during and i was
kind of frustrated at how everyone talks about
how the money how fiat currency is essentially
you know robbing from people and funding all these
kinds of terrible things but then no one was doing
anything about it other than talking about it
like how could you say oh yeah this is terrible
by the way all i have is fiat it just did not
make sense i was trying to live off of not fiat
and you couldn't really do that off of gold even
though i was trying with a you know one of the
peter schiff's debit cards back in the day it
was just doing what i could but it didn't you
know it didn't really work out and then someone i
i shared a lunch with a friend in chicago and we
had pizza and he paid for his part of the pizza in
bitcoin so i do have a bitcoin pizza origin story
and okay so that's how i got started with bitcoin
and then started using it you know for the for the
next couple of years and then around about the
end of 2015 i just decided you know what i'm too
excited about this stuff but i i don't feel
comfortable telling other people hey this is
awesome get into this if i'm just sitting in the
safety of my own like little non like fiat world
saying you know so in order to be able to you know
basically not be not be full of crap i decided to
only start living off of bitcoin and i did that
starting at the very end of 2015. somewhere about
six months in i closed my bank account as well
and started living unbanked and then by the end
of the year bitcoin became less of an efficient
means to that end and so i started using dash
instead for you know my everyday money and then
you know fast forward today and i'm still doing it
okay so just to let you know your
internet is coming in and out a bit so
i did just miss the end of what he
said but it's i got most of it um
so the crux of that essentially is that you're
living on banks you've been totally living off
of crypto since 2016 15 16. um i want to go back
just a second because you said that you had this
genuine just distaste towards the fiat system and
you know we often talk about inflation and money
printing and and all the of these things but it's
it's hard really you know to explain these things
to the ordinary person so what really um kind of
woke you up and made you realize you know damn
this system is actually um in some ways perhaps
you know stealing from me that's often how i how
i look at inflation anyway i look at it as theft
but yeah well it i guess it comes back to just
education i was kind of i was home schooled and
so i come from a more non-traditional educational
background a little more free thinking i guess but
still learning the history of money as anyone any
child when they're learning like what is money you
have that education of like well you know people
used to trade with they used to barter and then
they used to trade with these items and then they
finally found like precious rocks and metals and
then they turned those into coins and then that's
then eventually that became inefficient these
paper notes to represent the the actual money
and then at some point then there's just the paper
notes and i missed that like what happened there
like i followed the story all the way up until
the real money's gone it just disappears and
we're going to just play pretend with these like
paper notes because that would never have worked
in the beginning and that always puzzled me
but then also i grew up in the north of mexico
and right after the peso crisis of the 90s and so
like my grandmother had a bunch of old coins that
just didn't work anymore and no no those are the
old ones these are the new ones the new ones work
and like why do we have new ones oh the old one
the old currency just didn't work like and so i
always think like well that could happen to the
dollar too and i see the exchange rate the one
that i memorized as a child was seven pesos to the
us dollar now i don't know what it is today but
it's got to be more than like 28 or more and so i
kind of have that mental thing of oh this is not
this isn't just absolutely this isn't god-given
this is something that can fluctuate in value but
more importantly just goes down over time and of
course when you start to become you know i'm not
that old but i'm old enough to start remembering
when things were cheaper when everything was
cheaper i remember like if you had a 10 menu item
at a restaurant that was like super fancy it had
to have a bunch of seafood in there or something
yeah and then now it's like a basic hamburger and
a basic whatever it can get them to that level
and it's probably gonna be it's not even that
in england i'll just tell you it's not even
that hard yes i did um i did my post-graduate
university of buckingham right by oxford right and
so i remember those uk prices it's pretty crazy
yeah so but i think you make a really interesting
point sorry god i think there's a delay maybe
it's my internet go on sorry yeah so you did that
just you know the kind of long and short of it is
basically i never had this illusion that money was
perfect and then of course we start seeing about
nearly you learn about government and spending and
things like that and it's like okay well this is
much comes out of taxes this much comes out of
debt but they're spending more than all that and
then oh they just print money you hear about like
what does that even mean and then i like once you
once you basically have an education on how the
world actually works with it doesn't have to be
a tin foil that crazy you know what they're really
doing they're messing up the money you just have
to have a basic understanding that anyone who's
educated even who doesn't agree with but maybe
we would know you just how do you reconcile those
things and just think oh you just make fake money
well then if you can just make fake money to
pay off things first off why don't you print
more money and just buy everything like clearly
they know that there's some limits to this thing
and also if it is fake money why are we using fake
money you know like if if they can just do this
why are we just sitting and taking it just sitting
and living under a system that you know can pretty
much damage us and so when i heard about you know
the power of cryptocurrencies specifically about
in you know first bitcoin and then obviously later
dash and plenty of other ones i still just the
fact there's only ever going to be 21 million and
in order to change that you'd have to basically
get everyone on board and even if the people who
weren't on board you know they could still keep
using a version of the coin that they liked like
if most of bitcoin decided to just we're gonna
you know 10x the supply or whatever and i didn't
want that and like a bunch of people like that we
would just fork off and be using we'd still get to
use the money we wanted and just that that choice
is i mean it's revolutionary and i think that's
the underpinning of you know all cryptocurrency
all the value it creates i mean we have a
whole lot of different projects there like
infant inflation rates or just huge
supplies or arbitrarily change supplies
or things like that i think people have
lost the plot just a little bit on like
that's not the reason we came to all this
sure you experiment with other fun things
sure maybe have a slow like for example the way
monero does a tail emission or something a slow
permanent inflation but very small okay
that's fine experiment with those things but
just the sound money principles are kind of
why we're all really here if you think about it
yeah i want to go back a sec because you
said something really interesting which
um i really want to just echo for everyone you
spoke about your experience in mexico and you
sort of have these um memories in your head of
what prices used to be and you know you've seen
over time what has happened and i think it's only
experience which can really um help you understand
why we do what we do and i think this kind of idea
is the same in politics like you often have um
you know people coming from um previously
authoritarian dictatorship type countries
coming over to let's say the states and voting
republican because they understand you know what
happened basically um so i think that's really
really true and for you with everything that's
you know all the problems in terms of inflation
and everything that you've described which really
kind of put you off of the traditional
system and made you go entirely unbanked
do you feel that you've actually been able to
benefit in times of you know literally leaving
the system um i'm not gonna ask you specifically
um about taxes but you know in terms of taxes in
terms of inflation in terms of being more
sovereign you know it's been how many years
six years did you say six years five years five
five without a oh like five in a couple months
without a bank account so have you have you felt
and seen a direct benefit from that um so the
i would i definitely say yes it's a little
bit the i'm early to the process you know
especially because you know back in the day of
2015 2016 there wasn't a lot you could really do
with bitcoin you could buy a few different things
with it and then i was kind of early to the whole
you know scaling when the scaling wars started
with bitcoin and you know it kind of transferred
to more of a store of value and less of an
everyday payments thing it wasn't until 2017
a year later that bitcoin cash even forked
off and then that that's what most people
view is that but i was already living off of
dash for a year at that point because you know
and then at that time i think bitcoin had like
80 market dominance or anything anyway and so
uh switching to something less like an altcoin
is a term you don't really hear as much
today because it's just the space is so
diverse it's not all about bitcoin anymore
but back then it was and so there was there was
a lot of challenges along the way and that's for
sure but as far as have i benefited i would say
absolutely the one thing it's hard to really see
it because it's my daily life but then i see what
other people do and like oh i got my cards shut
off and this that like all this is terrible or
you know they just start worrying about purchasing
power or you they have like an overdraft problem
or just there's all these different things that
happen that you know i have my own set of you
know concerns to do but i like that i just all the
money i have is all the money i have and that's it
it's it's kind of funny the biggest thing is the
kyc hurdle and that's the thing is in this whole
thing i've stayed away from like kyc services
because you know otherwise i might as well
have a bank right and how do you do that well
i have a video series called how to live on crypto
that shows me specifically all those kinds of
things but basically uh the process of doing kyc
type services is just it's a huge pain in the butt
like oh well you gotta like do this you gotta get
verified here it's a big delay whereas if you just
have like have you ever received some tokens that
someone tipped you on twitter or something like
twitter's full hey titbot nano of course
why does that not surprise me uh but anyway
that's the thing is someone just goes here send
you some stuff and then now you have it you could
like that is such a it might sound a little dumb
trying to describe this as you know cool that
you just said but no it's so cool it's so cool
imagine if someone wanted to send you like a fiat
over the same situation where it's like
oh i want to send you five dollars like i
where's your venmo okay well do you have
one okay but before you do it you have to go
can you get the paperwork and get verified and
just you know do you have a permanent address no
if you're a nomad sorry you don't have permanence
you can't be banked like it's it's pretty crazy i
was speaking with the um the ceo of crepe of
a payment app um company and they they were
he was ranting about how he has to like
rent office space for like a lot of money
just in order to have bank accounts because they
won't take a post office box and they won't accept
a home address they're like a home business or
anything you have to rent you know office space
just in order to be have access to financial
services and if for example you're in between
like let's just say your lease you want to move to
a new place and then the old place um you know so
you're moving between spaces and then some problem
happens in in in with the new place that you all
of a sudden you can't you might have a temporary
period where you don't have a either home address
if this is your living situation or a business
address and then all of a sudden oh sorry the bank
you know you can't have a bank account anymore and
so just the freedom of being able to just send and
receive even you know crappy little tokens that
no one cares about but it doesn't matter just send
receive just i'll send you this i'll send you that
i'll send like bits here here grandma i'm going to
send you some over here hey person across the pond
i'll send you that and it just the freedom is kind
of intoxicating on that and once you try to go
back to the fiat system in any way or you observe
other people it's it's a little sad and you kind
of you kind of appreciate what you get out of it
yeah i think you know there's
so much there to unpack and
for me that was it was kind of the
access to financial services for everyone
which made me fall in love with cryptocurrency
bitcoin aside i'm not a bitcoin maximalist i'm
i mean i think bitcoin is the number one in my
opinion but you know i'm open to whatever and i'm
interested to see how things go um but you know in
terms of bringing people on the financial map it's
always been that which has just warmed my heart
mainly because you see governments and charities
and non-profits and all this thing for decades
trying to solve the problem of poverty trying
to help supposedly um and it's just a cycle and
nothing is really getting done and now you have
an opportunity where people can do what
the hell they want with their money
i always look at nigeria as like the most amazing
example i don't know what it is i'm just i'm
genuinely obsessed with the situation i find it
fascinating um in that they have insane capital
controls they have i think it's a hundred
dollars a month on international payments
how how how are you supposed to not okay how do
you get out how do you get out of a situation like
that like that that doesn't just stop you from um
you know building wealth or living day-to-day but
it stops you from creating a business it stops
you from bettering your life like you can't do
anything um so how so in terms of you living
unbanked how does it work how do you get your
groceries how do you do your everyday things you
know do you have obviously if you need a visa card
then surely you have to do kyc um but you said you
sort of didn't do kyc so you know you go down to a
pub you want to have we don't have pubs or english
whatever you go to a bar or whatever it is you
want to get a beer sometimes oh do you all right
so you go get beer in a pub and you want to pay in
with a card how on earth do you do that yeah so
just i happen to be blessed well i mean it was
a choice but i blessed nonetheless to live in
the fantastic state of new hampshire which is
kind of crypto ground zero where uh before gavin
andreessen came up here to some meetups and he
got the free talk live radio show he got them
their first bitcoin i think in 2010. roger ver
heard about bitcoin listening to new hampshire
radio show charlie shrem has been up here to me
as vitalik buterin eric you know eric voorhees
all these kinds of people are all here the first
bitcoin atm company was founded right here in new
hampshire it's you know because of that there's a
lot of uh businesses around here that will take
crypto directly like you know i want to get my
coffee and croissant down at the la de var in
portsmouth yeah i can go do that if i want to
go how do you do that wait wait how are you doing
that though so uh there is a company you can give
a shout out to any pay that they have a crypto
point of sale app that's super easy to use and
the people behind that got many although not all
of them but many of the merchants around here to
to to take cryptocurrency and so i go down and
i tell them i want to pay in dash because that's
what i have that's the best easiest spendable
money that i have and i and then they just enter
something turn around the ipad and there's a qr
code i scan it and i pay it and i'm done and as
far as i know all the businesses around here are
actually holding onto it which is not something
that you could probably see in other parts of the
world most would want a conversion option which
are available if they want but most places around
here just take and hold that and so they hold this
they don't turn it into usdt or anything
else as far as i know i'm not into people's
personal finances as far as i know they just
hold on to it and then spend it whenever so
yeah there's a few businesses that do that
i've been buying all my organic produce from
a farm up north that has taken all kinds
of cryptocurrencies directly for many years
and there's always as far as like the in-between
systems um there's this fantastic new service
that's come out you know in the last couple months
called dash direct that basically lets anyone this
is because i had to like spend years learning
how to do this kind of and having my little
world set up in a way that works for me but
dash direct basically allows you to spend
dash at 155 000 plus merchants in the us and
hopefully soon expanding to other countries
basically you walk into a merchant you they let's
say the total is 23 57 you enter that into the mat
into the app you hit pay it brings up your
dash wallet you pay for it there and then
it it presents a bar code that then you can
show and then they scan the barcode and you
pay and this is at like major retailers
whereas you know the places i spend dash
without a an app like this are minor or like small
like local businesses but if you want to go to say
you know a starbucks or a panera or something
like that or you want to go to a home depot
for a home improvement project then that's kind
of how you do it and you sometimes you can save
up to like 15 on this app and so i personally
believe that this is what's going to be the last
it's going to be the beginning of what we fight
that mass adoption because we've tried all kinds
of adoption things and it's just too much of a
pain in the butt for someone to buy cryptocurrency
and then try to figure out how to spend
it so people aren't going to do it but
if you have an app that just has a a geolocation
feature it just says you can spend it at these
five places right next to you and we'll even
like connect to your maps to show you to go there
and it's a super simple process of doing it
and you can save like let's just say five
eight percent or something on the purchase doing
it you're probably going to want to do that
and it's just an even better it's a no kyc
service and non-custodial because there are
some other services that are intermediary payment
things that let you pay with cryptocurrency like
i'm i'm sure paypal is debuting a thing of their
own but for example something like let's say flexa
which i'm not throwing shade at flexa because
any way you can spin crypto in the real world is
is good but there's a custodial element to
it and there is a qsd element to it and so
yeah that's that's basically what fills in the
rest of the gaps around those little those little
favorite places i like to go to to to spend it
directly where i know the owner is hoteling it
up anything else any of these big box type stores
i can use this one app and that just takes care
of just about everything else is it available
worldwide is it available in england you know
or is it just in america right now and they're
working hard on getting canada and then you know
then europe and et cetera but i mean it's a it's
a lot of work to do something i mean you know 155
000 merchants in one go and you know people are
already complaining it's not my country yet well
just wait this way that's a good thing it's a good
thing no i think that's a great thing if people
are complaining you know i'm shaking my head you
know people are obviously impressed by the service
you know no kyc and you can go ahead and spend
sounds what sounds like what dreams are made of
um so i have a bit of an interesting question for
you it's a bit of a side topic um and it's more
just about like relationships and friendships
really um because often people talk about when
they're involved in crypto um it kind of hinders
their friendships in the real world i'll explain
i don't mean because you're so head first into on
the internet and you become an absolute recluse
i don't mean that i mean more because i'm a
toxic maximalist and no one likes you anymore
just not even that not even that um because
mainly because um you start to see the world in
a different kind of a kind of way and you become
awake people often get very cringed out by this um
this analogy but i really don't care i think
it's fantastic you know you're sort of awake
to the truth of what is going on and often
your political views tend to fall quite in line
with your libertarian can you leave me alone
leave my wallet alone leave my money alone kind of
view um so i'm wondering whether you know you
sort of as you went on this journey because you
are fully unbanked you know so you're you're
fully believing in this you know you're not
one for in or one for out um whether that
kind of affected any of your um personal
relationships and people sort of thought all
right i don't know i don't know this guy anymore
yeah that is not at all been the case with me but
that's only because i took it the other way around
right a lot of people normies doing whatever and
then they hear about this cool technology and
then as they start that's like their first step in
the rabbit hole they're like oh i realize that the
money is fake what else are they lying to us about
and then it just goes down from there whereas
i already came from that direction you know i'm
just passing on the other way i'm just saying like
i already realized that they were before i knew
what what crypto was i already knew people were i
already knew the government was inflating away my
future i already knew that there was endless wars
being fought on my dime for you know no tangible
benefit i already knew that my rights were being
trampled i was being surveilled all this kind of
stuff i already knew all that coming in so a lot
of the people who i interacted with there were
you know a lot of the people who ended up being
ended up you know yes i that there has been a
shift in community around me for sure over time
but it it like the crypto is just the
latest part of this this whole journey
and i should also give a mention because when i
moved out to new hampshire not just because it's
a fantastic place to live and anyone should visit
especially if they're into crypto but it's because
there's this thing called the free state project
which basically indicates that everyone who is
believes in freedom again like this whole
red-pilled movement everyone feeling isolated
can come to one spot just move in one place it's
already it's called to live free or live free or
die is the slogan of the state like it's been has
freedom in its veins forever but everyone can come
here and just live free all together and not be
alone anymore and there's a you know reason why
so many headlines about all this freedom thing
you know is all out of new hampshire is because of
this kind of thing so basically there's a built-in
strong community of people here that are like that
so i would say any crypto person who's feeling i
don't know a little alienated a little lonesome
now that they they can't relate to their normal
friends anymore because they started on this road
well there's a there's a whole group of people
right here waiting for you that already believe
the exact same stuff and they're they're already
there with you they're not gonna look at you weird
for they're they're they already know you know
they're already already awake to all this stuff
um that's really interesting that it's this
freedom loving kind of safe haven did you
guys ever have a lockdown by any chance
uh not really there was some uh as it were
there was a there were some of these
governor's orders that were basically like
well you should probably wear a mask but if you
have for any any other loophole or whatever kind
of thing you can do so basically my life
has not changed over the last couple years
and there was some controversy over even
those very late kind of suggestive things and
the legislature immediately passed i mean
that was one thing that got done this year
restrictions on further emergency powers of the
governor so nothing even can be approximated
like that in the future and there were a couple
of businesses that got fined for operating but
the government refunded their fines which i don't
think that's happened anywhere else in the world
right that it's like so wait wait wait wait yes
so you so wait wait wait you've had no lockdown
and things have basically been normal
over the last 18 months roughly
yes so there was a a short period of like
a month or so that certain businesses were
not or not supposed to operate like to havoc
in in-person people for example and there was
a couple that got fined for not doing that and
after that got changed basically it was a very
very light situation like and even then that got
the ability to do so has been changed so that can
never happen again and the businesses affected
that were actually refunded by the government
incredible and so basically yeah we're we're
good to go for the future and obviously i'm
english so i don't know every single spot on the
map explain to me exactly where new hampshire is
uh it's basically so if you start florida and go
straight up yeah and basically right when you hit
canada it's right there oh it's right at the top
on the top yes it's very close to you know where
boston is it's very close to boston just north
of boston oh my gosh it's crazy i'll have to
come like i have to check that out i am a freedom
loving person like i for me freedom yeah i mean
for me freedom above everything um which takes me
on to so many other exciting topics we could talk
about um but before i go into that i do wanna i
do wanna actually get your thoughts on cbdc's um
i have a particular passion and dislike towards
them um i wondered whether whether you thought
that could potentially uh let's say replace
cryptocurrencies take down cryptocurrencies
you know do you like them yeah so i'm not
a fan obviously because the cb part is yeah
right so i'm like i have no use for them it's
not like like a lot of other people think that
oh this is what's going to start crypto adoption
for most people but like i've already been there
for a half decade like i don't need this stuff
um but so honestly like cbdc's are being billed
as something radically different and it's all it
is is fiat with more efficient modernized payment
rails that's just it like the entire and i always
like hesitate to speak too much on this because
from my knowledge i guess the european banking
system is significantly better than the american
banking system like the american banking system
is old and antiquated and terrible and modernizing
that i think is you know well here's the thing
i think it's a good thing i guess but it's still
missing the point it's still just it's still going
to be fiat because the magic of crypto is that you
can independently verify transactions anywhere
are we going to have a radically transparent
usd central bank cryptocurrency is it going to be
a radically transparent blockchain where you can
see all the money the government's stealing where
it's going are they really going to make that hmm
or also we transparent in one way like it would go
two ways it'll be one way transparent yeah and so
can you then can i send my usd coin or whatever
can i just send it to you on twitter to like a
random you know person on twitter with like an
anime character as their like profile picture and
just thoughtlessly like that and they can just
claim it well no so it's you know that's the
that's been the the kind of um stablecoin myth is
a lot of people have been very into stable coins
and sale coins first off they're paying to figure
out mostly and so the entire reason we got into
crypto was to not have a constantly devalued money
but so we made it make a crypto that constantly
devalues just like the dollar it's like a little
i understand for traders the only reason like
stable coins really exist if you ask me is because
they managed to get in into a regulatory loophole
where they don't have to do kyc and these other
things with the fiat system but they are still
kind of fiat but as soon as the if the government
regulated stable coins like fiat they would just
disappear overnight basically and the same thing
with you know cbdc's is it just no one's going
to be excited about this stuff unless they offer
something new are they going to provide better you
know freedom of transacting and fewer you know kyc
hookups and you know or kyc barriers and things
i don't think so because if it what if they do
though what if this the governments say you know
what this crypto stuff is is going to destroy us
so let's make a halfway crypto halfway fiat coin
that provides more freedom than fiat but still
people can have their transactions traced and
stuff like that i mean i still wouldn't use it but
that would be a net benefit for humanity i think
i mean i i don't think that's where we need to
be we don't need to care about that stuff though
we can already use you know better things
and i think that you know we talk about
you know the great el salvador experiment but also
other countries and stuff that are starting to
like once you can just say i don't have to develop
my own cbdc i can just adopt cryptocurrency is
legal tender and offer certain tax incentives
and stuff for cryptocurrency businesses and get
this giant industry just all there i don't i don't
really see cbdc's being like i think their par
their part in the world the new world will be
much smaller than the central banks issued old
currencies in the old world i hope so um i think
you make it an important distinction between the
european banking system and the american banking
system because you're absolutely right only up
until about a year ago did i know that americans
couldn't um do instant bank transfers for free i
know you have like venmo and all these things that
is weird we can um we can send money to each other
um for free instantly um so you know where i
kind of like woke me up to this stuff there
was a project that i don't know exactly where it
is today but a digital cache type cryptocurrency
based in the netherlands called golden and they
had a very interesting feature in their wallet
where first off they had like an auto converter
where you could send this cryptocurrency to a
bitcoin address and it would in the background
for zero fee or you know or zero confirmation so
instantly convert it to bitcoin and then send it
so it was like you can spend it anywhere golden's
accepted and bitcoin but you could also put in an
e-bond number into that into like your full node
wallet and then you send it and up to a certain
amount per week or whatever it was like no kyc
you could just send euros to someone's bank
account and i just thought that was like wow
you mean you get to just send someone money and
the government doesn't need your id like that's
really cool i mean obviously a very small limit
like 50 euros a week or something like that but
i still you know i was like if you want to send
five dollars there's gonna be like a five dollar
fee or something or more and then it's gonna be
you have to do your id so yeah that's kind of
what woke me up funny that crypto instructed
me on the differences in the banking systems
yeah it always does it always wakes you up to
the problems and things that you didn't know but
yeah like i said you know we can just send like
10 pounds um instantly for free and it's it's
super easy so i'm kind of fascinated by the fact
that you can't um but my my thing is that cbdc's
will be marketed so well and i think one of the
ways in which they'll be marketed is we'll be
told that it'll be better for the environment
you know we'll be told that it will help save
the world in terms of poverty because it can be
programmable and you know we can make it um you
know we can make it work for these certain things
and food benefits and this and that and it overall
it's just a more efficient enslavement machine in
that it will be easier to probably do what they do
as far as the marketing thing i'm not worried
necessarily about that because one thing i've
learned over you know it's a hard lesson
maybe that you know i already kind of
understood before i understood better over
time is that the free market is undefeated
you can tell people what is going to be valued
or what won't be valued and so like for example
whenever you look at the coin market cap rankings
you just like what what's that one doing up there
how come people are investing in this and
you try to say like people are wrong people
are stupid it's like no you're stupid not stupid
but you're like you don't understand i don't know
i don't know joel i don't think no so sorry i am
cutting you off but yes my problem is my problem
is like i think the majority of the world is very
much asleep and if the last 18 months has shown us
anything it's shown us that and i do think that
people are always looking for an answer they're
looking to better their lives and i do believe
that this will be marketed as a way to better
their lives you know um you know air dropping
money and lots of exciting new things that you can
do with money i do think it will be marketed as
this shiny new coin which will help solve poverty
like i genuinely think and i genuinely believe
that people will believe that and they'll also
be told at the same time that things like bitcoin
are bad for the environment other cryptocurrencies
they're scams it's anonymous it's dangerous and
that will deter people away from that yeah so
i sort of disagree that that's where the threat's
coming from i do agree that we will have threats
from cbdc's but it's a different direction
i think that the threat from cbdc's is
all their old fiat gets turned into new fiat and
the tracking and analytics of this new fiat will
be ten times worse than what they already traced
for your payments before i think that's the real
problem where people get to see every little
bit of money that gets sent they have much
better because you know blockchains are radically
transparent and you know maybe not to the rest of
the public but they'll be able to do it i think
that's the trojan horse now that people don't buy
bitcoin because they heard good things about
it over the last decade or so i mean they've
been the whole you know it's a scam it's a this
it's a you know drug money it's all this is bad
for the environment yet the price keeps going
up because there's a demand for it people want
to b basically the number one thing that
cryptocurrencies have solved which i thought
it was gonna be number two or three or four but
it turned out to be number one in the short term
is it lets people make money people want to make
money like it sounds like the stupidest thing i'm
ever telling you of course everyone knows you want
to make money but that's why people love dogecoin
you can devise them and then you can get
ahead in life and it the investing like
if you haven't spoken to ken bozak yet i believe
you should because he's he's i believe also
unbanked on crypto but he's a completely opposite
kind of end of the spectrum he's into the nft
craze and all that stuff but he got into crypto
because he wanted to invest when he became he
started to see some gray hairs in his beard he's
like i'm an adult now i need to do adult things
what do adults do well they invest and so he goes
to his bank and says i heard about this snapchat
thing i want to invest in snapchat and they
just laugh at him like you're not an accredited
investor what are you talking about like you can't
get in on that and so he got really sad like i
tried to be an adult i couldn't and then he hears
oh i can just buy this bitcoin stuff and i don't
need to be a fancy credit anything and so he does
and it gets in and the simplicity of that story
that i tell endlessly is that people just want to
be able to the average person can't really invest
there there's always like these barriers between
them and this the average person can buy basically
whatever they want with their card for example
but they can't invest so that's the number one
value people want to invest and make more money
and they can't so crypto does that for them
and if the cbdc says oh it's this is it's all dark
money over there and use this one they don't care
because they can't in they can't buy like 50 you
know a hundred pounds worth of e naira or whatever
the hell they have going on yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you know
and then like all of a sudden they're gonna
make get it rich off that it's not gonna work
so they're not gonna do that they're gonna buy
bitcoin dogecoin whatever else they're gonna buy
you know they're going to liquidity farm and stake
a million times over with the d5 and get 200 extra
rewards over like that's what they're going to do
and unless you stop them from doing that they're
i don't see cbdc's stopping that in the slightest
i just see it as replacing old fiat with increased
surveillance powers i definitely agree with you
in terms of um increased surveillance powers the
the privacy that we have now the small amount
of privacy that we have left will certainly be
um made even smaller um but yeah no i i'm totally
with you know this we're so lucky and i talk about
this all the time that we are in a market which
is so brand new um the kind of gains that you can
make right now you certainly won't be able to make
in like 20 years time unless it's in a new kind of
emerging market um and you know that kind of takes
me back to the problems with the education system
which i'm so so passionate about i i absolutely
think it's it's uh you know a waste of time and
energy and um well actually it's not a waste of
time and energy because it's it's created for a
purpose and to be a certain way and to create
certain types of people um but what upsets me
is um that we we don't know how to invest we don't
know that we need to invest um we don't know what
inflation is and a lot of the time which i find
so fascinating is people often come to bitcoin
not because they know that there's a problem but
because they just sort of heard a bitcoin and it's
new and it's calling it shiny and then you get
there and you're like oh [ __ ] there really is
a problem thank god i have it you know i don't i
wouldn't know what to invest in if it wasn't for
bitcoin and my time in this industry yeah
also investing is a luxury for a lot of people
about this and this is where you know the red pill
moment where you hit into like people don't oh
people are you know i don't want to be hyperbolic
but why not yeah yeah do it people are people are
debt slaves they i mean i don't know how bad
it is in other countries but at least in the us
you don't own the house you oh the bank owns it
you you have to make constant payments or you
become homeless and you don't own the vehicle
you drive you know there's a loan on that you
make a payment on that you a lot of times buy
stuff with a credit card and you have that bill
to go and you just you're locked into bills all
the time and so you go to a job that you hate
and you know pay tons of taxes on it and you you
need to because otherwise your life falls apart if
you don't have that constant stream going in and
where do you have any money to invest and see it
go up you're stuck in this just you're stuck not
getting ahead in independent because once you have
money once you have enough money to a certain
degree i mean more money at some point is just
more money but like at some point it enables
you to be free and once you're free you start
questioning things that your government's
telling you et cetera et cetera and so
that's why only the big fish get to invest in
the legacy systems but then imagine if you own
your vehicle you own your house you don't
have debt on that although you never own your
house in the u.s because of property taxes because
you have to pay on money taxes every year and just
owning a thing but that's a different story but
so what if you own that stuff you don't have
debt all your money is your money you pay your
bills and whatever's left over you're like well
i'm gonna spend half of this on going out and
getting drinks because i'm a human being but the
other half i'm gonna go put into something that
i think is going to go up over time and you just
over the course of a few years you now have an
investment that you know could have done poorly
but could have done fantastically well especially
if you get to you're allowed to invest in the
newest things like let's say cryptocurrency as
opposed to just like all the you know whatever
people invest in right and then all of a sudden
you can secure a future and you're not just locked
into the thing now you can tell your boss that you
know what i don't think this is the right career
for me i've done it enough i'm going to go start
my own podcast i'm going to go start my own small
business i'm going to do whatever else because i
have the investment given wealth now to be able to
do that but you can't do that if you're locked
into the debt slave system and especially like
i think a lot more people would seek to get out
of that if they knew they could just you know buy
some dogecoin or i don't keep bringing up those
guys i hope people don't buy dogecoin because i
don't think it's going to be going on forever
but it's an example of if people have a goal
they can change their life but if people are just
like well i have to be really rich to actually
invest then they won't even try to invest at a
small small level it's funny i had a a i believe
is doug scribner who's the ceo of an atm company
a bitcoin atm company i interviewed him one time
he told me that the the lower class for their
investment is lottery tickets because like every
every you know paycheck they get they buy a
few lottery tickets and yes mostly for nothing
but that's literally how they invest like they
put it towards chipping away at the percentage
chance that they will have an investment
a retirement money someday and so i mean
that's a little sad to think that that's an
investment thing but it's also a genius that
even people with i would say the lower levels
of financial education understand investment and
they understand that they should be investing
even if they do it through like maybe not the
most advisable things by like i'm going to hit it
big someday i'm going to throw they they're still
trying to invest what if those same people instead
of going to the lottery ticket machine go to the
you know let's say the the bitcoin atm and buy
whatever like i'm gonna 100 and people do this
by the way they go like put a hundred dollars and
then they get some put their phone up and they get
some crypto out of it and they just repeat
by over time and yeah then all of a sudden
oh in a few years like you you put 500 worth over
the course of a couple years and now all of a
sudden it's like 5 000 or something now you can
afford like a vacation or something for example
now you can go take a nice holiday and it's you
can afford it without yeah so yeah i don't know
how to conclude that whole thought you don't need
to conclude it you don't need to conclude it you
know i'm totally with you i think that it's really
just like the land of opportunity and sometimes i
do sound like a broken record but for me this
entire space is the new 21st century american
dream where we are so early and um also because
it's so unregulated you know how like a lot of
um industries and a lot of major players were able
to achieve so much back in the day because there
were less regulation it was true capitalism um
and that sort of reminds me of what we have now
and yeah i'm you know i'm totally with you like
i said before you know i wouldn't know what to
invest in now now i know like if i do want to
start investing in the stock market now i know
um and i'll you know i'll think about that when
the time comes um but what for me everything and
i think also for you everything sort of
comes down to this idea of freedom um so
we have like a few minutes left so i just kind
of want to um get your thoughts on really just
if you could just summarize why you feel freedom
is so important particularly in today's day and
age you know where we have lockdowns we
have um and i will say you know coerced
vaccines and and things like this and you know how
bitcoin comes into play and everything else you
know why for you is freedom um so important oh yes
so i'm going to start with a hyperbolic statement
that's not it's not like the other ones which is
you know a little bit more true but it's okay and
this is more conceptual right is without without
lack of freedom is murder let me explain that uh
we are born under this earth with a ticking time
bomb of how many days do we have left before
we're gone and i mean people have all kinds of
different real religious metaphysical opinions
and things like that but one thing that everyone
sort of agrees on is this is we have this life and
i don't know if we have anything else like once
once we're old and we die that could be it for
what we are as a person just we're gone right
during this time you have nothing but endless
possibilities that's the beauty of life you can
do anything you want you just why like i want to
become a karate champion and you just you can do
that right oh i want to you know become a i want
to you know surf for a living or i want to invest
and have a giant like boat and just like drive
around whatever your ideas or dreams or whatever
you want to be a scientist i want to invent a
new something i want to go to the moon i don't
care people have all kinds of things and freedom
is what lets you do any of these things and
so literally when you are upset that someone
you know someone dies or gets killed it's
like oh that's that's a tragedy well we're all
ended we're all headed for that direction and
the problem is their freedom is cut off short
they run out of options of things to do in life
let's say they're like 24 and they get into a bad
vehicle accident and they they're gone like it's
not that well they were they were always going to
die but because they died so early there's so many
possibilities that are not there for them anymore
and in the same way if you can't pursue your
dreams because you're taxed too heavily or you
regulated too heavily or whatever if you can't
live life to your fullest that is a slow murder
it's a slow death of all the different options
and things you could do with your life you're just
locked in and you know it's it's just a you know
it's a long torturous existence and so that's
for me what freedom is is the ability to do just
about anything and the economics is a great way of
measuring i guess human potential although it's
it's just one metric because you can't measure
like the human spirit and its achievements
in a objective way because there's just so
much that can be done but with it's kind of
an interesting thing to see when there's more
freedom like objective freedom
like people can do what they want
then the economy takes off like people build
more things people have more food they have more
everything it just and so that's a sign that like
freedom is synonymous with human flourishing and
we want humanity to flourish don't we i
want myself personally to flourish i want
you to flourish i want everyone to flourish
and so if we're free that's what happens
and so it's freedom isn't it it isn't critically
important it's everything like what do we have
if we don't have freedom everything we do in
life we work hard so we have money so we have
the freedom to just live in our house we
don't or freedom to go someplace we whatever
that's all we aspire to do is the freedom
to do what we want and basically the only
reason people don't value freedom is either
they're using they're using a lack of freedom
to further their own ends as in they're they're
literally preying on people they're predators
or they their freedom is too plentiful for
them to see i'm still here yeah freedom is only
uh it's only seen with a contrast so if yes
correct yeah it's just like as i say like freedom
freedom is like water in that no one's gonna pay a
lot of money for water but it's so crucial to life
it's not until it becomes scarce that you see the
price go up you know pretty basic economics and
so same thing with freedom people have been able
to do just whatever they want for the most part
in the in the developed world at least and this
whole like you know well well just just put this
mask on do this just don't worry about that like
those can like that won't last very long because
once freedom starts to become more and more scarce
that pumps up the price the price of freedom is
going to go through the roof pretty soon we're
going to see that and these kinds of poetic
speeches of like oh it's everything and when your
freedom is restricted that's like a slow murder
and all this hyperbolic nonsense i've been talking
about won't be necessary because the market price
of freedom is going to go through the roof when
it gets restricted people in 2020 as far as i know
over a hundred thousand people left california
and over a hundred thousand people left new york
because of a lack of freedom and they
moved to freer parts of the united states
you don't think that that's going to happen
even more in the world you don't think a bunch
of australians are just never going to find a way
on little rafts across the ocean or whatever they
do to get the hell out of that dystopian hell
hole and find a free place you don't think we're
going to see the free market adjust for this
spike in the price of freedom due to scarcity
i think we will it's a really interesting way to
look at it i think everything does come back to
supply and demand um i talk a lot about that
in terms of like happiness in life versus um
like entertainment value and and all that sort of
thing but yeah you're you're totally right i think
freedom is the most beautiful thing
that we can have as humans and um
i think it's so sad to see that it eroded and to
see people not understand the value in it and this
kind of comes back to what we're talking about
at the beginning of the conversation when i was
sort of saying you know only experience can really
allow you to understand and what i would say is um
because it's just like what you were saying was i
think life has been too easy in the west you know
like we haven't had a real war you know we haven't
had a real war in a long time not that i want one
they're not at all we won't even i don't
think i don't think we'll have one i don't
think we'll have one in the same sense that we
ever had one you won't have men on the ground
but anyway it's another story for another time but
um you know like you said people have become um
it's like water so you don't realize the value in
it you don't realize it until until it's gone like
you said you know it's super it's just there and
you can't you can't see what you have until it's
gone and i think that's the problem i think that's
also why people are so easy to hand it away and i
actually watched um charles hoskinson hoskinson's
um video uh yesterday yesterday i don't know if
you saw his talk about vaccine passports and
he made a he made a really important point
um which i think is really hard to um articulate
articulate which is a real problem that we've had
because people often say what's the problem with a
mask you know what's the problem with the vaccine
what's the problem with this what's the problem
with that it's not so much that in and of itself
it's more about once we've set a precedent for
mandating um taking away these certain freedoms
that precedent and that power can then be used
in a very bad way in years to come and then he
compares it to blockchain technology and you know
let's say like bitcoin for example and how you
can't change those rules those rules are set in
stone whereas now we have these emergency powers
lots of things can happen um yeah i mean that's
exactly true but what a lot of us don't realize
is this isn't where the precedent is set
the precedent was still a long time ago with
the non-emergency powers think about all the other
things oh you have to you know you have to have
a license to drive a vehicle well that sounds
reasonable right everyone should you know you
have to get a liquor license because this is you
know potentially dangerous what's next you have
to have a sugar license because super can kill
you probably faster than you know maybe not the
now call but you know what i'm saying like it's at
what point at what point do we start to abdicate
our freedom and our responsibility it's not at
where we decided to let people mandate masks and
vaccines that's just that's just the most obvious
and latest trend but it started a long time ago
and that's when did we let people say you must use
this piece of paper for money otherwise you're a
criminal if you try to use gold for example when
did we let government tell us we couldn't trade
with whatever we wanted you know legal tender laws
right like that wasn't that a huge red flag wasn't
that a huge precedent set that then they can just
determine what we use and yeah i mean that's the
thing about you know obviously cryptocurrency
but also just the freedom movement in general is
it's about it's not a resistance it's a roll back
we're rolling back all the mistakes of the passage
and bit by bit this was not good let's make
a better version so money is a great way to
start because you know you start with money
and then what else can you do how can you
give people more rights how can you you know all
these like antiquated laws and so like for example
i remember a few years ago there was a law in
new hampshire on the books it was unenforced for
like 100 years that made like adultery a crime
that if you cheated on your spouse that was
like a crime and it was just on the books
because like no one enforced anymore because
the world moved on but it's still uh one of my
friends saw to it that that law was repealed
and it's you know yeah it doesn't no one's
life changes but it's still a mistake of
the past roll it back yes that's
kind of all we're trying to do here
so just lastly then um i guess like a in a
one-liner do you think that we will ever get
to a point in society because society i i'm old
enough and smart enough at this point to know that
sentiment changes um so do you think we'll get
to a point where sentiment changes and freedom
will be much more will be truly valued and um
at the forefront yes absolutely and i think it's
i think it's already happening very fast the thing
is uh what people don't necessarily understand
about freedom people a lot of people who are
the biggest freedom advocates don't understand
necessarily that the freedom is also the freedom
to not be free and a lot of people will choose to
live in places with different jurisdictions that
inhibit their freedom because they kind of like
that i think they like that it just oh they do
there is a choice for the people who care about
freedom to go there then what happens over time
is the after effects of freedom like the whole
idea of america like this is not a special country
this is just there's so many beautiful countries
all across the world the only reason why anyone
cared about america to begin with was because it
had a better freedom climate than anywhere else
and then people saw it people didn't think oh i
like the idea of freedom i'm going to move there
they just saw stuff was going great here and then
they wanted to move and it's the same thing about
like there's hellhole places in the us that most
people are leaving right and they're going to
other better areas that have a freer jurisdiction
just not because oh conceptually
freedom but because they're like
where i live has a ton of crime it's extremely
expensive i can't go outside without covering
my face i can't go to my restaurant i can't i this
is the better i'm going to go to the better place
and so basically about is is freedom in our
future absolutely for the people who choose
it and over time the free market right in a
competitive environment between unfree and free
the best solution always wins and the freer places
will rise to the top and then the people who chose
the unfree places will start to change their mind
and they won't know that it's because of freedom
but it will be because of freedom absolutely
it's the same as people leaving california
to go down to texas to vote democrats they don't
know why they're leaving they don't know why they
they don't like california but they'll wait for
the same rules which ruined it anyway um joel
it's been such a pleasure um this was so last
minute um but it's been so interesting talking
to you so i want to thank you so much for coming
on yeah no problem it's been a distinct pleasure
as always absolutely and guys thank you so much
for watching don't forget to tune in next week for
another amazing discussion most probably around
freedom and bitcoin all right have a great day bye